hey guys I want to create a quick video
on a question that I recently had how
long does it take to fix a fatty liver
okay well it really depends on three
things number one how chronic it has
been how long have you eaten bad foods
for your entire life or was this just a
recent thing or how long have you been
drinking so we have to factor in your
past number two how extensive or how bad
it is has is it so bad that your entire
liver is filled with fat are you
developing scar tissue as in cirrhosis
do you have a chronic viral thing which
is causing hepatitis so those are all
things that you have to look at as well
and the number three how perfect or how
good is your current diet okay are you
doing it partially are you sort of doing
it on the weekends so these are the
things that you'd want to look at the
longer it's been there the longer it
takes it could take up to three years
but realize that you would have to be
consistent doing eating very very
healthy every single day for a period of
three years now the actual fat in the
liver could go away within months okay
but that doesn't mean the liver is a
hundred percent there's other factors
there's the structure of the paddle site
which is the the liver cells that
actually do the work and that takes time
to get those to work a lot better so the
type of keto that you need to do is
called healthy ketosis I put a link down
below for more information about that
but hands down that's going to be the
best thing for your liver you don't want
to do the high carb diet for a bad liver
you want to do keto low sugar low carb
and a lot of vegetables and moderate
protein healthy ketosis is not a high
protein diet okay so because large
amounts of protein could strain the
liver you want to do more organic food
definitely more cruciferous vegetables
for sure fermented vegetables do things
to improve your gut your flora your
friendly bacteria you'll definitely want
to do in a minute fasting because that's
that's going to take a lot of stress off
the liver and intermittent fasting is
vital because it takes the stress off
your liver every time you eat you kind
of stress the digestive
so if we do them it fascinating we give
the liver a chance to fully heal and you
want to work up to about a 20-hour fast
in a 4-hour eating window ideally
because that's going to put you in a
state of recycle mode where your cells
are going to recycle old damaged
proteins okay and you'll create a lot of
healing in the liver it's called the
Toth Ajit choline is a real key nutrient
for the liver especially for a fatty
liver you it actually is Lippo trophic
it helps to strip off the fat from a
fatty liver I would also recommend
taking the entire vitamin B complex with
it in the form of nutritional yeast okay
but put the choline in there you can get
it in a tablet or a powder and this will
greatly speed up the results alright
thanks for watching so if you don't have
this book you might want to check it out
it's entitled it's not lose weight to
get healthy it's get healthy to lose the
weight healthy ketosis and in a minute
fasting check it out I put a link down
below